Ideally, we want to test more people. That will give us a better indicator of
whether or not the drugs are effective. We also want to give each drug to very
similar groups of people. This is why we randomize. And we also want to test a
large dose of the medication, because we really want to see how that will
effect the subject rather than other factors. Larger samples result in higher
power. Remember the standard error of the mean? When n increases, the standard
error decreases. Lower within group variability also leads to higher power. We
can be more sure of significant differences when the distributions aren't
overlapping. However, if the variability increases, Its harder to tell if
there's a signficant difference. And finally, choosing treatments with strong
effects sizes will increase power. To do this you can make treatment conditions
last longer, make them occur more often, the treatments could just have strong
effects. Or you can make the treatment conditions last longer, make them more
intense make them occur more often etc. These are all ways to detect whether or
not theirs a signifcant difference.